خارج الحسابات هو عنوانه تحقيق الجديد
لبرنامج ما خفيه اعظم التحقيق فتح ملف
تصاعدي عمليات المقاومات في الضفه الغربيه
المحتله خارج حسابات اسرائيل الامنيه
والسياسيه هذه صور حصريه عرضها التحقيق
لافراد من كتيبه جنين التابعه لسرايا
القدس الذراع العسكري لحركه الجهاد
الاسلامي
الكتيبه التي كانت افرادا معدودين قبل عام
ونصف من الان باتت اليوم تضم عشرات
المقاتلين في صفوفها
مئات من الشباب يريدون الالتحاق بصفوف
الكتيبه واكبر دليل على ذلك انك تجد قطعه
سلاح للشهيد يحملها بعده شخص اخر لا يوجد
لدينا قطعه سلاح للشهيد بقيات بدون رجل
يحملها هنا صور حصريه لعناصر من كاتبه
جنين اثناء اعدادهم قنابل وعبوات محليه
الصنع باساليب بدائيه وهنا يقومون بعمليه
تجريبها قبل ان يتم استخدامها فعلا في
استهداف الاليات الاسرائيليه كما تظهروا
هذه اللقطات التي نطقت قبل ايام من بث هذا
التحقيق
شراره المقاومه تمددت هنا في نابلس حيث
عرين الاسود نجح ما خفي اعظم في لقاء عدد
من مقاتلي العرين الذين ينتهيجون مؤخرا
سريه جديده في ظل الاستهداف الاسرائيلي
والتعقيدات الامنيه هذا احد مقاتلي العرين
الذي فشلت اسرائيل في اعتقاله مره عده
لمشاركته في تنفيذ عمليه اطلاق نار قرب
مستوطنه شابه شمرون ادت لمقتل جندي
اسرائيلي قبل قرابه ثلاثه اشهر
وصلنا العربي
مخزن كامل
الحمد لله رب العالمين
عن غزه واي من خارج الحدود وتسعى كما تقول
لضرب القيادات المسؤوله في اي مكان عاندين
نحن نعرف منذ زمن عن وجود القيادات التي
تدعم الارهاب وتدخل الاموال يوزعون
الاموال على كل من يرغب في تنفيذ عمليه
ارهابيه وعليه فان طريقه الوحيده التي
اراها هو عدم رؤيه هؤلاء الاشخاص كبشري
يعيشون مثلنا على وجه الارض
ان شاء الله
خلال التحقيق كشف الجناح العسكري للجهاد
الاسلامي عن عمليه
اختراق اسرائيليا لصفوفه ووجه ضربه
مجند مزدوج من غزه حمل الرقم 106 نجح في
اختراق صفوف المخابرات
الاسرائيليهم حيث تمكن بعد اشهر من
التضليل من لقاء ضابط المخابرات
الاسرائيليه في القدس والعوده مره ثانيه
الى غزه دون انكشاف امره لكن الاهم هو
نجاحه في تصوير ضابط الشبكه الذي التقيه
وكشفه هويته الحقيقيه وايضا كشف نوايا
المخابرات الاسرائيليه في استهداف عدد من
قاده المقاومه واساليب تجميدها